hey guys welcome back to the swish water
podcast and i know the episodes haven't
been as consistent last few weeks as i'm
flat out with the tasman marker at the
moment but stay in the loop through the
woodland social media for when episodes
are coming out
and to get all the deals and speaking of
deals boy does our major sponsor swoosh
have a deal for you 15 off your swish
order if you use the code what a lad and
if after all this time you still don't
understand what swoosh is well then let
me explain
say your mate jaunty loves bowdoin
barrett so as a gift you can give jaunty
a personalized video message from
bowdoin barrett you write down exactly
what you want him to say or give him a
general guide jonty watches the video
and it makes his day but what the best
thing about it all is that up to 70 of
the money you spend on that boat and
barrett video will go to kiwi kids
charities it's a very cool platform all
the lads are on it so click on the link
in the bio to go get amongst that
also the absolute lad regan todd from
the champion harness stable todd's
racing have partnered up with what a lad
and they have an offer to become a part
owner of the hopefully champion horse
water lad who is progressing very nicely
you get all the perks of being a horse
owner for the very small cost of a
thousand dollars which covers all the
costs until 2025
and by then hopefully we'll be swimming
in his prize money anyway
but in all it's a bit of fun and if
you've ever wanted to experience horse
ownership this is the perfect way to
start also go follow todd's racing on
facebook and flick me a message if
you're keen
lastly the lad and the business guru tim
bateman has an opportunity for all water
led listeners so listen up to this
cheers jimmy
are you looking for an exciting career
for life after rugby
my name's tim bateman and i've been a
professional rugby player for the last
17 years
my plan for life after rugby was to get
into the well-being and recovery
industry so i built ostudio new
zealand's largest well-being and
recovery centre
despite the challenges of covert we've
seen consistent growth in our business
and we've decided to expand o studio
throughout new zealand and abroad
it's an exciting time for the well-being
industry and we're looking for top lads
to be a part of it by opening your own o
studio
if you're interested head to ostudio dot
co dot nz slash lad to inquire back to
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah what a lad well today all of you
water-led listeners are in for an
absolute treat with one of the biggest
lads in the game he's widely regarded as
the prince of picton who has gone on to
become a northland tanefar legend and
along the way throughout his incredible
journey he has played for teams such as
the tasman marco the melbourne rebels
and the mitsubishi dino boars he is one
of the absolute great sinners they're
great dan hawkins welcome lad ah good to
be here jimmy it's a true honour and um
thanks for having me bro mate good to
see you again i'm looking forward to
this yarn but i do want to start with
something current like how good are the
tiny cars going at the moment you boys
are on absolute fire
yeah the boys the boys are going well um
we've got a good mixture of experience
and um young lads coming through and
to be honest it's been a big offseason
probably the biggest since i've been
there um
obviously after last year we uh only won
one game so
they really put the foot down we've got
new facilities here and whatnot and um
the boys were getting stuck in like it's
been a lot of commitment from the boys
you know and in the off season and it's
starting to pay dividends i reckon so
but it's only early days jimmy you know
you must remain humble and um
any team can be any team in this comp as
well as you know and um yeah but
enjoying the ride at the moment that's
it it is an incredibly close competition
eh you're right every team is pretty
much beating every team at the moment
but i remember talking to big red tom
robinson at the i must have been late
last year and he he was really talking
up the tony far chances um i know the
tap weren't having a bar of it i think
they opened you guys at 250 to 1 at the
start of the year but i'm sure a few of
your mates climbed into that yeah well i
think early on we've murdered a few
people's maltese that's for sure so um
yeah um and i'm sure a few boys climbed
in today we've got a few
very faithful fans up here and it'd be a
beautiful thing if we can get the pay
for them
but it is always a good culture up there
like i know everyone talks about how
good the tanifa culture is up there even
when you're losing so i could imagine
how good it is at the moment when things
are humming yeah it is a beautiful thing
it is um
it's it's almost like sometimes we're
that close that it
it goes against us you know we enjoy
being at each other's company and we um
you know in the past years we might have
stayed up a bit late with each other
before games in there because we just
love hanging out with each other and
[ __ ] you know um but now it's all
starting to pay dividends i think and um
yeah it's good has anything changed with
that um side of things or like i
remember even tom was saying how
um probably the lack of professionalism
costs them sometimes is it still a
little bit like that or has things sort
of started to flick a switch there oh
bro it's come a long way since my early
days there
back when i first started out you know
it was um
definitely not as professional as this
now yeah i think we're in a good place
now but um
you know when i first got there
we're doing every now and then we'll do
two day on the bears and a short
turnaround you know back then that was a
long time ago but now you know um
we want to do anything to win and
everyone's brought in so
tommy's right here i think there's been
a massive switch i don't know if yeah i
spoke about it before there's new
facilities like um we used to be in our
meat works you know our gym was pretty
humble
and um well i don't mind but you know
young fellas like a good german or not
finally goes right you can just walk out
into the field and you're into it so
yeah everything's sort of coming
together but um
yeah
day by day
and mate last time i caught up with you
you were
sitting on the sideline after a red card
and made the same thing again one of the
real grubs of the game what's that two
red cards in two years
talk me through this one two red cards
in my whole career jimmy um
oh for
some unintentional thuggery um
yeah
it was 80 minutes up the southland and
the big lot got a bit of a break through
a hole and i happened to be at fullback
and he kind of liked me up and i kind of
hired him up and um
yeah i'm not looking to get punked on
national tv so i went in hard
he came in hard at me and unfortunately
i clipped this clipped his chin with my
shoulder and um
down he went but
oh yeah as soon as i seen him go floppy
i was a bit i was pretty gutted with
myself and um
yeah it's just part still part of being
a warrior and then the day sometimes
these things happen and he's a real good
sport big joe shout out to big joe from
southland chatted to him after the game
and he actually said sorry to me about
getting a red card and i was like
i was like what a gentleman
yeah i need to settle down a little bit
on that but um
yeah i need to drop that you know that
would have been a beautiful shot if it
was a couple inches lower
i think so anyway yeah but um
yeah but you're out for a few weeks then
yeah i i
it was four weeks i just found out
before four weeks but um
i can lower it by doing a safety
a safe tackling course so hopefully i'll
learn something of that jimmy
[Laughter]
no more reds
yeah i'll be tackling like a tree
gentleman right around the ankles after
a safety course
and your return is what against tazzy in
about
what three weeks it's first tassie you
wouldn't read about it oh my god
that's a beautiful thing you know and
nelson i think yeah now i'm hoping i may
i've been actually played a mitre 10
game in blenheim
we're you know close to picture where i
grew up but um
yeah it's a nelson hopefully i'm
involved anyway you know it's tough to
even get the 23 and the tinies at the
moment so
hopefully i can get back in there and
bring a bit energy the depth mate a
caged up dan hawkins is a scary sight
for the tasman marco fans that's for
sure oh i'm going to be i'm going to be
nipping at the butt i'll tell you that
but
if they were going to move one game to
pick them that was probably the one the
return of the prince well
they might have forgotten me and picked
them by now to be fair it's been
it's been been a huawei they used to
hang a few tunney's flags around them
picky but
um those days might be over
i'd love a game down the domain there
don't get me wrong yeah
how good would that be but 12 years ago
since your tazzy debut mate is such a
long time ago when you look at it like
that but you're still only 31.
how's your body holding up is your body
sweet played a lot of footage yeah nah
the body feels real good at the moment
um
i've had it yeah i've had it it's gone
through the ringer a little bit i've had
spinal surgery and um also snap my my
tibia foot um in a game there's taranaki
i actually
that was my fault too
the ball kind of bounced up and um
one of the necky boys hit it pretty hard
and i stuck my my leg out to foot trip
him and you know those farm boys have
got those hard bones yeah and he just
ran straight through my bone i looked
down i was just flopping by some skin oh
straight
so um yeah i had that and then i had a
shoulder surgery so three surgery it's
pretty um standard
for a guy who's been playing for a while
you know you've had a few yourself jimmy
yeah what did you do to your back
um
many a year ago oh this is where i
pinpoint where it started i fell off a
ledge when i was over in england it was
quite slippery
and um i slipped off this ledge
i had a couple too by then
a couple quiets behind me but slipped
off this ledge but it was quite high
and i had it like on my tailbone i
landed on it and at the time i jumped
straight back up i was like yeah you
know i was pretty um
it was nice and warm from the liquor and
um got straight back up but yeah later
on
uh i started having big trouble with my
hammies and whatnot
and it was actually candy when i got
back to tasman candy yeah blessed the
old physio there yeah she gave she
clicked me a bit and stuff and um
my hammies come right and stuff but i
feel like that's where it started anyway
as my career kind of went on and
at the melbourne rebels was where it
really um started to to hurt me um
i was living with reese hodge actually
had to put my socks on in the morning it
was getting that bad bro that wasn't a
very bad way it's probably the worst
injury i've ever had mentally as well
because i was creeping into my
day-to-day [ __ ] you know you'd wake up
and um
you'd be like what's the bet going to be
like today
yeah
yeah eventually if i had to get surgery
on it
because my leg was getting numb and
whatnot and uh
but best thing i ever did getting it
sorted because it feels good now and
yeah so talk to me about that ledge how
high was it like one story up and how
did you just how did you fall off it
i felt like i got hit by a bus it was
pretty high
it was pretty high but it was probably
like
i don't know like uh
maybe off a roof of a house sort of
thing
yeah true far out onto concrete like
yeah i wasn't real high but yeah it was
onto a concrete it was onto a solid
landing
and like at the time i bounced up before
yeah
and was that just like a trip or
were you trying some
tsunami skins move
oh
i don't even know what i was doing yeah
yeah we were i think yeah we're outside
of some pub
things had finished up and
i honestly can't remember
we might have been running it straight
at each other at that stage
i actually can't remember i slipped up
and um that's where i pinpoint it back
to
i could be wrong mate i thought i
believe you that that would probably
wreck you back doing that so
that's probably where it all started but
i'm keen to hear about the rest of your
um footy career but i want to start at
the start um growing up i know the urban
sort of legend is that you grew up
living on a boat how true is that one
who told you that
that is true though it is true
now
yeah
yeah if i go back to the start when i
first moved to picton
uh yeah i kind of had the choice to go
with my mum or dad when we lived in
christchurch and i went with my old man
and we went up to pickton
and yeah um
he's a rugged customer at the best of
times my old man and um we ended up
living on a boat for quite some time and
uh
yeah it was a great place to grow up
because there's there's many a character
and
um there's many a bizarre individual i
guess you could say and a lot just a lot
of legends and whatnot at the time and
um
at the time it was one of those places
when you were 15 you could get into the
nightclubs and um oh there's all sorts
of skullduggery going on but
there's still that community feel to it
you know jim
yeah yeah so
um
yeah and then obviously
went to school there and we're
only a small school of 300 or so but we
had a good first 15 at the time so um
and still boys that i loved to this day
we uh
we went well in that um in our own
little comp there
there was some little bit of temptation
to maybe go to a bigger school like
mulberry boys or
maybe nelson or whatnot but
it's not really my style i i never
really want to sell out on my boys there
and um
so i stayed strong queen charlotte and
it was a good decision because
yeah i learnt a lot and enjoyed myself
there
and then i
went on to waitoi obviously and uh
had had a good good first out of school
season um
and made tasman
as a 18 year old in the marcos and um
got to play off some of my heroes like
yourself to me
and robbie and tommy marshall and um
to be honest bro i i think looking back
i was way too green for that level of
footy
you know i'm really i really got on the
play club footy
kinda didn't know much about structure
at the next level when i was kind of
playing off instincts at that stage
and um
like when i got into the tassie team you
know uh professional footies to level up
with structure wise and whatnot
especially being a team
and uh
i think another thing was just being
from a small town and
and whatnot and
for me being a team having to order
around dudes like chris jack and yeah
like i'm like how am i meant to tell
that dude what to do you know he's a
legend and it took me a long time
to get my head around that
and i guess another thing was
i was going through quite a bad court
case on the other side of things off
field i got myself into a little bit of
trouble i was defending a mate
my friend got attacked with a baseball
bat and um
a couple was jumped in and it was really
short short of fear and it was over but
uh he happened to get quite hurt the guy
that attacked my friend and um
yeah it opened up a big saga off-field
for me and um it was quite looking back
like um
yeah it was a lot of a lot of my
shoulders as a young dude especially how
much i want the crackers and footy as
well
had two things sort of going on so i was
at training in nelson i don't think i
told many of the boys or nothing but and
then i'd shoot back to blenheim and go
to the courthouse
i could have a laugh about it now
because um it was pretty scary at the
time i got to say it was some heavy
charges in it
and we ended up dragging on for a year
and a half and um
and it went to a jury trial and whatnot
and it was scary but looking back now i
can laugh we obviously got found not
guilty on self-defense
um the whole time like
it was self-defense and it was just yeah
i don't know how it really got to that
stage but
looking back now there was some funny
times like uh now i can laugh about it
like um
we got one time we went back so i got
this um
the scholarship to go do you know
remember reunion that rugby show that tj
used to run oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah everybody on that show there
was um
they were giving away a scholarship to
go to their iran's academy oh yeah and
up north and um
yeah and i won it because tj was a bit
of a picked in dude i don't know if it
was a bit of a setup or not but he kind
of chose me to do it because he i think
he's from hevlock maybe or just the
other picture
um so i think he's trying to help a
young fellow out and i won this
scholarship anyway
at the time this was actually before
tezi just before i got into tessie but
um i was still on in trouble with the
stuff and uh
i had to go to court to be able to go
there i had to get off my curfew to be
able to go up
to this iran so i had to go into court
and it was funny very like i had this
like lawyer he you know he's a
battle-hardened lawyer and stuff and um
we went into the the courtroom
to try to get off a week off this curfew
so i could go up north and um this
female judge comes out and um man she
was on a mood and she was scary and uh
she was like nah i don't like the
the lawyer said whatever like i want dan
to get off so he can go up north and
pursue his rugby career and whatnot and
she's like uh
she's like nah i don't see why he should
be able to go anywhere right here
and um he sort of said his thing and
then the police actually said nah like
we want him to go to this the sirens
course and um so the judge finally said
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna let him go and
um anyway i walk back out
and um
this lawyer comes out he's just talked
to the judge in there and he's come out
and he's sweating i'm like comes out
he's like bro did you he's like did you
see her and i was like yeah and he's
like i was like why are you sweating and
he reckons he was um he's like i've just
spent 30 minutes uh ducking estrogen
bombs here
he's like
he's like don't you mess that up because
that chick was crazy and i was like all
right but he's like a battle hardened
lawyer and he's sweating bullets i was
like man let's check this chick wasn't
messing around so
um yeah and then
ended up going up to iran's to the
academy and um for a week i think it was
and it was good it was good fun
and a wee story about that one was we're
doing um
our video videoing us sprinting
and um this i did my sprint and i was
like oh sweet i got a bit of a funny
running style at the best of times
that's a kind of scuttle um like crab a
little bit but um the follower was
videoing and he was like oh dan derrick
and i could use your your video to show
the boys and i i was sitting there
thinking yeah yeah yeah like
i think i thought he must have thought i
looked good in full stride or i'd pull
this technique was saying whips it up on
the big screen he's like boys this is
how we don't want to run
look at this
i was like oh
he didn't tell me he just put me out
there he's like
that's how we don't want to do it but um
i i could see the funny side of it bro i
always have seen the funny side of it
and there yeah
at the end of the day i'm still here
playing i don't know how many of those
boys are still going
and yeah the last laughs jimmy right so
much for that you've gone through uh
because you were 18 years old
playing for tasman this massive court
case on your shoulders geez that must
have that must have been a tough time
yeah it really was bro like i could
laugh about it now but um
at the time
it was scary and um
because there's a real chance maybe
going to jail or whatever but um
i had to kind of try to prepare myself
for that and then i was also you know
trying to
crack it in professional footy and um
i think for any of the young i think
that time trying to get into to mitre 10
cup especially even you haven't been
through an under 20s program and stuff
if you're
from club unheard of it's quite that's
quite um stressful because you know
that's your shot and um
and you're kind of working you know
you're doing all this other stuff
and you finally get a crack and um you
want to make the most of it and um for
me i didn't bro i
my time at tezzy
i was just too raw and i had that stuff
going on and i wasn't good enough at the
time
so unfortunately the next year i didn't
get back him and um rightly so too in my
opinion um
but you know these are the uh trials and
tribulations of life agent how was that
to deal with
it it was hard it was real hard
because you know i you know
i really
professional footy was a big big goal
for me and um
i felt like i failed at the start
and
you know i was i was like well maybe
this is it but then time kept going and
i got hungry again and um
actually in between that time
between my time at tasman and
coming up to northland
um
kieran kane the coach
of uh
okay like obviously kkk
we were together on the same team what
was that thing you used to say when
there was um if you did something bad
was it chop your [ __ ] off yeah
oh i i did one too many cut you [ __ ] off
the fences and then get back in
i'll tell you that
but anyway kk actually invited me up to
because he's a picture man as well and i
think he had a bit of a soft spot for me
and um
he actually invited me up to his house
and tucked in a beautiful house too
overlooking the
the bay and that and um
as it was i think it was an intervention
that's the way it seemed anywhere
and i went up there and um had a bit of
a drink with him and i walked in he's
like
danny hawkins what the [ __ ] are we going
to do with you
i was like
that's how i wasn't going to go good
he's like at this time i was trying to
sit i was in a bit of a i was but i was
in a little bit of a lull
uh staying on my mate's couch and
whatnot
and he must have heard about it and got
me up there and he goes gets me in
anyway and he's like
daddy dan hawkins you remind me of me as
a young fella and i was like oh
here we go
and he goes
i don't even know if i can say it he um
he's like when i was your age i was
sleeping on the couch just like you and
um
he's like
when i was 18 i actually um
tried to beat the [ __ ] out of my dad and
i was like
i was like
he's like yeah i see a lot of pent-up
anger in you and i was like okay i don't
know about that but um
and the yarns went on bro the yarns went
on i don't can't even get into a lot of
them but um
i i like i was from a place of love you
know that he took me up there
but at the same time
when he spoke to me
i knew my time at tasman was done
because he was still the coach at that
time and i
i think it's an important thing
as a player to be able to read when your
time might be done and read because as a
business we know this and um
that's when i felt okay i've got to move
on
like i could play
wicked at club or whatever and i i don't
think
i'm going to be an option for them
anymore so
when that happened um
my mind kind of said well maybe i have
to move on somewhere so yeah
and how did the northland gig come out
that's that's the story in itself too so
like just around that time when kk gave
me the intervention um
there was a mob reverse nelson game
that was like the trial for tasman yeah
the marcos yeah
and um so that was a big game and there
was a fellow that come from auckland i
won't say his name but he wanted to get
first five as well when he was on the
mulberry team
and he wanted to make tasman and whatnot
and um we were both on the same team and
the mulgra coach ended up putting him at
second five and met first five yeah
and he was actually a first five and he
um i think he was pretty pissed off
about that and um
we kind of went into the trainings and
stuff with marlborough and
like i felt like a line out would go in
like i'd call a move or whatever i sit
and um the line out would go in and i
could be coming off the top of the line
out and he'd like change the move on me
or do some weird [ __ ] and um
you know my skullduggery radar was going
off real quick like i felt like he was
trying to like make me look bad like
maybe i was like thinking into it too
much but anyways it happened quite a bit
and in the lead up to this game and um
like i was like enough's enough i gotta
like not set the bud and i had to have a
chat to him
i was like bro like
what's going on here are you trying to
like make me look bad
because you're trying to you want to be
first five for tessie as well whatever
and he's like
right here and he goes
and then he starts to get real nice to
me he goes i've actually got the name of
an agent i'll give you like a good word
to the agent and um
and this and then i was like cool and
then we actually made good friends and
we're all good now and um
and this agent ends up ringing me anyway
and this guy because this guy's giving
me a good word and he's like oh dan like
right here i'd like to take you on and i
was like awesome like
and he's a good mate for this day that
my agent ben boyle from orbit management
he's a good fellow and um
he said like all right like dan there's
a there's a spot actually i think
ashmore wiki just left northland oh yeah
and he's like there might be an
opportunity there for you um if you're
interested and
at that time going to norfolk never
really crossed my mind
um i'd only really seen it on the
weather map when it's always got the
little sun icon on it
but and saying that david hole was
always one of my favorite players and um
it just felt right to go there i don't
know what it was but something just told
me go
and i went and it worked out well
i think and i think banksy was at their
time trying to get in the tassie as well
yeah and so banksy ended up getting in
and obviously the legend goes on you
know how legendary is there man
so it went what it worked out for all
parties you know yeah awesome oh well up
there when you were there when you
arrived ah he he's finished his career
but he still lives up here and he's um
he's on a farm
and um yeah i chat with him quite often
you know he's had a lot to do with me
and um
he's a real good like yeah he's just
he's a hard man and he's yeah he's good
to have a chat too you know if when
times are tough or times are good he's
got plenty of good yarns
mate so many similarities in your games
right it's some people have sit there
and it's an honor to even be you know
mentioned in the same sentence as the
man you know um
yeah it's cool you know especially as a
guy that i loved as a young fellow
you know now we're mates and i'm i'm
i've been in his jersey you know so it's
cool
mate how good is that and talk to me
about when you first got up to northland
how did you find it obviously like you
said coming from pick down
up to the
far north how was it yeah it was
actually um
it's probably a perfect match picked
into northland um
in a lot of ways uh i actually really
thrived up here when i i first got to
the airport and i didn't really you know
i
was
on a whim and um a fella arrived at the
airport looking for me and he had like
bailing twiners as um as his belt
he's like oh this old following he's
like oh you dan hawkins like yeah he's
like you're with me and he um he took me
to a place called kaiwaka it's kinda
south of whangarei
probably about 40 minutes south of
whangarei and um it's kind of
farmland this is the club i played for
when i first got here because i only
came up here it was no contract or
nothing you know i had to earn it i come
up here to try earn a contract and um he
took me out to his farm he was on this
long dirt road and stuff
he's oh you know this um
it's it's not the greatest place in the
world but we'll have you out here for a
few days and um
we'll find you something better in town
he's like really downplaying his house
and stuff and i was like oh
i'm sweet you know i've lived on a boat
as you said
you know so i can live anywhere sort of
thing and i took me out there
and it was like a 1800s historical house
and he hasn't done anything to it so the
walls are paper thin and but it was
awesome but i was on like a a river the
the kuiper river so it's like overlooks
the river but it's a real old school
house
and he kind of we kind of only ate
meat from what he killed on the farm we
didn't really go to the supermarket or
nothing like eggs from the
chickens and whatnot and um anyway i was
out there for a few days
and he's ah we'll find you that spot in
town right here and um i was like oh i
actually quite like you do you mind if i
stay and he said oh he's like all
surprised
and um i was like i'd like to stay i
love it here because um
we got on real well his son lived there
too he was a good fellow and um we
started getting a bit of a routine he's
like sweet yeah you can stay and um we
started getting a bit of a routine going
like i'd run the driveway
and um don't do a bit of farm work
then we'll come back and uh would come
back into the house for a chanui we
drank a lot of chanui that's for sure
and he's like he's just an old school
character bro and he's like he's like um
he's like a father to me up here to this
day you know we're still good friends
and i always go out to that same house
all the time yeah it's all about what a
day now
but i always go out there and um
yeah it's just he's here he's always had
my back and he's one of the legends you
know um
man that's so cool and such a humble pad
it was it was brad and
for example like it was he would one
night i woke up and i was like a shotgun
bullet went off and i was like woke up
pretty startled and i got up and went
outside to the veranda and he um
he was out there with a shotgun he's
just shot a possum that was keeping him
awake
and he had those like mangroves farm
socks on and those you know those um
those v cut undies you get from kmart
with the shaving ass
he had those on the shotgun and i was
like what are you doing triving he was
like he's like oh it's bloody possum was
keeping me up and this possum got blown
the birds like just [ __ ] like blood
everywhere
i was like i was due to ledge you know i
loved it and um i ended up staying there
for like probably two years true you
know
yeah i didn't go to town for like three
months i never went to whangarei the
actual city up north for probably three
months before once i got there
um that was a wicked way i felt really
comfortable i think it was a big thing
for me i felt comfortable out there and
um it was like that zone i could go
once i made like the northland wider
squad in there i could go to training up
there
and you know that was pretty you know it
was full on and then i could come back
out there and i was comfortable and it
was just quiet and
i could relax and just yeah chill out
chill out with the chanue how good yeah
chill out
every time
so then your form obviously was good
enough to then make the northland squad
was that just from club form
yeah yeah that was just purely from um
club footy i did i went winner right
when i first got up and played some good
club footy
actually the funny thing is the first
game club was versus david hall
yeah which was a huge honor you know and
um
yeah i went all right and anyway he got
signed for a couple years and
obviously had to move up to whangarei
and whatnot and
yeah and i started from there really and
i was living with uh dan pryor yeah it
was just dan and philia another fellow
philia so i moved in with them and dan
really you know he looked after me well
and um
he's a very good mate to this day um
kinda so i got him the squad and ben
seymour another super rugby player he
was the other team here and he was a
good player himself so he was kind of
like the marquee dude
and i was just i'm behind learning and
whatnot and um
we had a few games and stuff i think and
um i don't know if benny got injured or
i don't know what happened but anyway
dan dan pryor he had a bit of quite a
bit of power you know he was quite well
respected and he um he's in a leadership
group
and he kind of said to the coaches um
like oh you should just give this baller
a bit of a chance he's like i know he
runs funny and he takes money and [ __ ]
but you should give him a shot he's got
a bit of heart or whatever
this is what he told me he said anyway
but um anyways yeah so
when he come out that day probably about
four games into the season and um
he came out and he said he's like oh
you've got your [ __ ] you've got your
shot don't blow it and i was like what
do you mean he's like you're starting i
was like oh
work it so you know i probably owed dan
got me my first start
and um
yeah then it was hawke's bay was my
first start and
it was a weird one it was just um
everything just felt real good and
just really calm and confident bro and
uh
i can hardly remember the game it went
really well like it was weird it was
like almost in a bit of a like a flow
state or something um that's the dream
everything come off you know yeah you
know when like every kick bounced like
this far and i bounced out
like perfectly and i think i dropped in
the pocket for a quick drop goal and oh
everything was going right bro and then
yeah i ended up starting for the rest of
the season and
yeah from then on
yeah been there for 17 games now i think
so
so what was the biggest switch from your
time with tasman to your you know your
first game with northland was that just
time and experience that made you feel
that comfortable and be able to get into
that state
i don't yeah
i've always thought about that i think i
was definitely
far too green
as when i was at tasman i was 18 and i
was playing for my team waitoi but we we
didn't really
play much structure like i was just
playing off instincts and then yeah
some reason i felt really like
comfortable when i come up north i was a
bit older and
honestly i think guys like dan dan pryor
he's a real relaxed dude
and obviously uh rini rooster rangy he
took me under his wing pretty early and
um
you know like you know he's sparking up
a ziggy right before training and that
made me feel pretty calm
and i believe it or not
for some reason that made me feel real
just relaxed and whatnot
so um
i don't know i think i was just being
older and um
because every team i've been in there's
been legends there and um
i think yeah that was the main thing
just being older and
as a team
i feel you've got to you've got to earn
the trust from them and uh you've got to
earn their respect you probably feel the
same jimmy and um at tasmania even
though the boys they were awesome to me
i never felt on field i owned their
their respect really but up north i i
felt like i got their the boys respect
and i felt like um once i got there i
was away and it's funny how it works
because i was pretty much the same
player just a bit older and a bit more
wiser i guess but
it's that switch i don't know it's just
that you can feel when the boys
respect they they trust you to lead them
i think that's the main thing and i
could feel they trusted me to lead them
around the field and
you know so 100 percent that confidence
is that confidence as a tense so key and
to get that sort of support from a
couple of those senior guys oh makes
such a big difference they just sort of
let you know that you're doing the right
thing and that the main guys the key
guys have got your back so
you can just sort of go out there and
call what you want but like you say like
when when the team doesn't quite trust
you you don't feel like they trust you
mate it's a tough gig
it is it is
it's hard to shake you know
you can shake it i reckon but um
you know in your head when when you got
there trust or you don't yeah no yeah
so and one thing you had to do
throughout your career is sort of juggle
because you're semi-pro like your whole
career this up until this time oh you
were juggling work
um with 40 how did you find that yeah
yeah like at the start
i feel like i go right back to tassie
when i was juggling both um i was
working at the meat works
and on the slaughter floor
yeah yeah it was some big days and
whatnot but um no it was all good i
enjoyed it and but they were just long
days that's why
i think that that beginning but when
you're first trying to crack mitre 10
it's probably probably the toughest for
a lot of guys because
man you got a lot on you know you got
you got work then you got to go to
training and then you got gym and
whatnot and um
then you just got the pressure of trying
to make it you know so
um
yeah i juggled it all right and then as
my career went on i went to japan for a
few years and went to
the melbourne rebels and stuff so i kind
of went fully professional
but um
i haven't minded i quite like
the actual
going back to work side of it as well i
i don't mind that you know but um i
think yeah it can be a struggle and
a lot of the young guys coming through
you know i realize it can be a struggle
and i like i take a real bit of pride
now trying to help them you know
and um
yeah i know what it's like talk me
through working on the slaughter um
floor
whatever it was how brutal is that yeah
yeah well the first day
when you turn up
because there's a lot of rugby boys in
this like it was kind of a bit of a
hookup through rugby yeah
and
there's a lot of boys from opposing
clubs and stuff and like you're walking
and there's blood everywhere and then
like there's the boys up high on the
where the cow first goes up on the
chains and now like when a new person
comes in they smash their knife on the
thing they're like they say some [ __ ]
some kind of chant
and it's quite intimidating yeah you
roll in there's just blood everywhere
and these big mongrels with knives just
smashing on the thing
but luckily i knew i knew a lot of them
you know and i played versus them and um
actually bit a lot of them so yeah
i could walk in there with my head held
high you know
so it wasn't too bad in that regards but
then um
your first job there was just um
your first job is just
pushing blood into the drain with a
with a like a squeegee yeah so that was
my first job there just doing that and
then you work your way up then i ended
up working my way up to the gut buggies
what an honor to the gut buggies what do
you do there
so there's like four there's four
buggies and
the carcass comes around
the cow and it's been a bit of the
skin's been taken off in there and this
guy comes with a knife and slits it
right down the gut and all the gut comes
out and it falls on this little silver
buggy and like my job there's four of us
and you had to dissect the
the gut so you take the kidneys the
spleen
all that stuff off because they use
everything
and but you gotta dissect it without
cutting the actual gut and contaminating
it yeah so there's a bit of an art to it
but gotta write it at the end but um
there's all sorts of creepy [ __ ] going
on there bro like we'd go down the line
because some of the cows are pregnant
and you know there'll be little fetuses
in there and do to pull them out and
it's just [ __ ] weird but that's kind
of it's just blood and that kind of sort
of stuff and it was just a good group of
ads though um
but it is quite confronting especially
um
like it's not very nice seeing animals
you know they the cows fall out and they
land on a stun table
and then because it was um
so
the guy who kills the cows he had to
pray that was all blessed
it's quite interesting how it all
happens but
within like 45 minutes the whole cow's
box like every part's pretty much used
and it's all in a box and stored away so
yeah it's it was it was a good it was a
good job it was all right yeah it was
just gory man
had some weird dreams to start with you
know you didn't mean
i would struggle on that one i don't
think i'd last a day
yeah it's not for everyone that's for
sure
but up in northland you did mention like
you're juggling your work uh and footy
and then you get the opportunity to go
fully professional like you said with
the rebels how did this opportunity come
about
yeah um i think it was after my second
year with northland
uh 2 14 we had we had a pretty good
season and um
i played fairly well and um
yeah uh the rebels sort of came calling
i got a call from my agent saying the
rebels are interested and very quickly
they were they said yeah they'll take me
and
so that was that was massive and an
opportunity i look forward to um
melbourne is actually where my mum's
from and it's probably where i become a
little um glsen in her eye you know
my is where my mum and dad met and so
it's kind of a little my dad's actually
played club footy there back in the day
so it was a little connection there so
it kind of felt like it was meant to be
and um
that was cool i went there and um the
boys there were primo like uh
top leads as you'd say jimmy and um
it was just unfortunate i was really
struggling with my back
before i went there and it wasn't a bad
way by the time i got there
and um
yeah it's something i'll probably never
know how you know you kind of need to
start to see how you'd go um
but
it's my bet it was just one training my
back was getting that bad that my leg
was going numb
so
like the doc said like go see a surgeon
right here
um
so i did that and then
he said like you got to get surgery
and
i think i played three games for them um
just bits and pieces like you know
you'd hardly even i'd hardly even call
myself a real
melbourne rebel to be honest but i guess
i played a couple games but um
yeah then i got that surgery and it was
it was really it was just it was just
nice to get my back right um
the surgeon said it took here to take an
extra half an hour to bore a hole around
the nerve because it was so like
tight on my nerve because i
during the pre-season with the rebels i
had a good preseason and but i could
feel my kicking like
the meters on my kick were going down
um just all those sort of things like i
wasn't moving very well
but at the same time it was an
opportunity to play super footy and i
was trying to i was trying to man it out
and uh it was a big pre-season over
there um
it was pretty physical and stuff and you
know when you're not one of the big dogs
you're on the pads and yeah you know
yeah you're getting smashed day in and
day out and um
probably didn't help that i was sleeping
on an ear bed as well
why were you on an airplane
you mentioned you were living with
budgie yeah i was living with hodgie
because it's quite hard to find
accommodation there and um well you can
but it's quite expensive in that and
hodgie had this little um little office
say like a little computer office
it didn't even have a door it just had a
little uh like curtain
and it could find it could fit a bed in
there and i was like ah i'll just chuck
a earbud down i chucked it down
and then i had it was tiny though but i
had this lace because we got like a
living allowance and um
i bought this with the living allowance
i bought the 60 inch tv and it pretty
much took up the whole room so i had an
airplane and just the tv it was like a
cinema it was wicked
yeah
so um but uh it was cool and um
it was a good time there but um
obviously everything happens for a
reason and
my back once my back went it was a long
road to recovery but
finally a funny story is though i come
back to new zealand and um i always give
out my gear you know all the rebels kit
and stuff yeah
and um
i went i gave some this shirt this rebel
shirt sort of my mate and uh anyway i
come back to his house one time and his
dad his dad rolls in with it and um it's
like this melbourne rebels shirt and
he's gone along but he's ripped all the
sponsorship off and stuff so it just
saves rebels
and i was like oh like rob what's what's
the go with that um
why do you take the sponsorship and
stuff off and he's like
oh no no it's just it's been a good show
it goes real well down the um clubhouse
because he's in the rebels motorcycle
gang oh yeah
you know
so he's like taking this it's got pink
on it and [ __ ] and he's taking like all
the sponsorship off and it just stays
rebels and he's like ripping it at the
the gang house at the river's paddy
what was different with the rebels over
there like how did they do things
differently what were the lads like um
the lads were cool bro it was like um
when i first got there i was like they
must like almost already knew me like
there was mikey harris oh yeah tom
english laurie weeks
uh sean mcmahon and
um yeah there's just now like i was real
surprised there because um
talking to like kiwi boys
before i went there they were like
some of them were like well rugby's like
a real private school
boy thing in australia like um
there's that kind of scene and i was
like oh
i went there and and they were just the
coolest dudes they like they looked
after me real well and um i still chat
to them to this day and we had a lot of
fun and
yeah and tommy allison was there toms
right and um that's a that's a you know
he's he's one of my heroes you know he's
there's something about him he's got a
lot of money to him and um i always
catch up with him now and then when he's
i actually caught up a couple weeks back
we played wellington yeah and uh it's
cool to see him and yourself doing so
well in the coaching ranks and um
you're going doing the coaching thing
now so so how long was your rehab from
your back
and is that why you didn't get
re-contracted
yeah yeah well
yeah i didn't really get a chance to put
my foot forward on that it's probably
rehab
to be honest like it
took a very long time to come fully
right but yeah probably like eight
months before i could play so i signed
back with northland and come home
and i had to pass a medical
and i got back and we had to do like a
return to play sort of thing it was
still pretty sore and this like the
physio he's quite a skinny dude
back then and um i had to do some
tackles with him and he'd tackle me you
know to get back into contact
and um we did that
and
i after that that night i had to crawl
to bed like i was in such a bad way and
it was just a fizzy you know it was just
uh
he wasn't a professional footy player
put it that way that was gonna hit me
so i actually had thoughts of hanging
them up for a little bit just maybe for
a year or
maybe for good because i was my back was
in such a bad way and um
but
eventually like
because i was meet the past lucky i knew
the physio he's a good mate and he um
he kind of said to them look give me
some time i can get them right because i
had to pass the physical to get the
contract so i gave me some time and
pretty much pushed it right to the last
second and one one morning i just woke
up and i could like touch my toes again
and
i just i just freed up it was just real
weird and
it kind of come right so
i don't know what it was but
yeah it was it just come right one day
like not fully right but
good enough to play and um i made a
successful return to play so it was good
and then off to japan yeah yeah yeah
that was um
got a call from
the coach of the dynabors
who's a good mate of mine george he is
he was actually the northland coach as
well so then he went to japan and um
their first five there he
had had too many concussions and he
they um just needed a short term
replacement
just for i think it was four games
and yeah i jumped at the chance um and
went over there and
when all right yeah it went pretty well
and got re-signed then we had another
season so like for the mitsubishi
dainaba was like you played second of
two for it jimmy yeah i remember playing
you actually yeah yeah yeah we did it
and um but for mitsubishi they really it
was their dream to get to the the top
league you know that was
i don't think they'd done it in like i
can't remember how many years because i
remember i first turned up mikey little
was there oh yeah yeah yeah and he said
to me like bro if you help us get to top
league they'll build a statue of you or
something
i'm not true
anyway so like the season goes on we had
some cool foreigners like like mikey
little and um maddie vlanga some great
great players from new zealand yeah and
um anyway we end up playing and we get
to the
you know the promotion relegation game
where
determines whether you go up or not you
play
i think the
the top teams in the the top four teams
and the second div play the bottom four
teams and the
the top league to get get up and that's
how it works and um
we had a game i think we're playing
toyota shock you're saying and it was
like i knew
i was hearing whispers about um the dyna
boys are going to sign a big name 10 for
the next year
so um i think
it was colin slade and i heard like i
was hearing whispers so i knew
but i knew that i had to have a big game
to stay around
and i just knew the japanese people they
kind of reward people that do
good for them do you know what i mean
and um
so i kind of knew this game it was all
or nothing and um
if i i felt if i played well and we won
they might resign me and
take us both on um
so
yeah like there's a lot there's a lot of
pressure but um anyway the game went on
and i had like
one of the best games of my life
back in that flow state jimmy you know
it only happens once in a blue moon but
um
it happened in a few crucial times i
guess you could say a huge moment and
anyway we we won it yeah and we won it
and um
and ishii the the big dog you know the
big guy yeah the diner boys he ran out
in the field he like sprinted out to me
he's like okay son i want to play with
you long time
and gave me a big hike
and i was like yeah and he's like come
to my office and got resigned the next
week and i was like oh
it's like beauty so i ended up doing
another yeah got another season with the
boys it was good
yeah it was actually a special game yeah
i bet um as a young a young picture kid
you never would have thought that you'd
be playing over in japan playing
professional footy yeah it must have
been pretty crazy nah
never did i think i'd never thought i
think i'd play this many professional
games let alone japan let alone super
rugby then yeah i think that's what's
been massive my gratitude
my gratitude towards like
how far i've come and um
just going to training with the boys
every day i'm just grateful you know um
it's it's massive in every game i go
into you know
now i'm i'm
i guess i get confidence from it because
you know i never thought i'd do this
much and everything now
that comes from now on is just like an
extra you know and um
i hopefully got a few more years and me
i'd love to play a hundred for the tonys
that's that's a big goal of mine
and um maybe get over to america or
something but
i think um
gratitude's a a huge thing in my life
now and
um yeah
mate i love that and you i can feel it i
know that you can see it with like even
hearing you talk about your whole career
you always you're always so grateful for
every opportunity you've got and people
that you've met and where rugby's taking
you it's uh pretty cool to hear and you
also mentioned that um northland
uh your dreams to sort of play a hundred
games for them what are you on now and
is that how long have you signed up
there or um yeah i'm
i'm on about 70 i think or something
like that
69.70 um
but if i keep getting these read cards
it could be a long road
10 years away
yeah exactly um
now i'm only signed for this year but
um yeah we'll see what happens um i've
been pretty happy with my form of of
recent we've kind of
we've got rivsa young a young 10 who's
been he's been starting the games and
he's he's a wicked player and um he's
been doing really well but i've just
been kind of been playing a role on the
last 30 coming off the bench and um
somewhat yeah closing the games out or
whatever
needs to be done i've actually um
i've quite relished that role at the
moment
in the helping ribs as well anything he
needs
um i'm there for and um i think that's
been another thing you know and um in my
career is um
as i said earlier just reading those
situations you know uh
just knowing i'm afraid i'm in my 30s
now
that maybe i've got to play a backup
role every now and then and just just
relishing it and
hopefully from there you know i can keep
going
you know i can still start games and
whatnot and
those times will come but if
if the tunnels need me to back up or
whatever i'm you know willing to do it
but uh
yeah i'm happy with everything that's
happened apart from this red card so far
[Music]
so hopefully where i can
come come back and keep going the way
it's going and uh yeah see what happens
from there
mate you're such a lad but one thing we
haven't discussed you've mentioned a few
times is your um goal kicking technique
it's it is a very unusual goal kicking
technique i'm sure you've had many a
kicking coach trying to change your
checkers but mate you you still hit them
from everywhere kick it i don't know
probably around 90 percent you're on
fire every year
yeah
it's um
something i wasn't always good at
actually i went over to overseas for a
little bit in ireland and i kind of it's
a long story but i got stuck out in the
middle of nowhere kinda in a house and i
they didn't get i was at a club playing
footy and they didn't give me a car or
nothing so i ended up stuck in this
house but there was a rugby field
next door and um
i spent pretty much you know most days
down there just
continuously kicking and even when i was
at school and picked him to be honest i
was just i'd always be kicking
you know it was something i enjoyed
sometimes i just chucked the headphones
in
and just go for a kick you know
something is quite um therapeutic and
anyways i just just messed around with
my style and stuff and started
started feeling that
what was best for me was just taking out
the run-up pretty much like
i think the less run-up the less margin
for error
and um
yeah
my my kicking tee i actually made myself
as well to this day it's the same tea i
constructed it myself
and um
yeah i think i'll frame that one day i
love you too
yes it's um
yeah it's handmade
taylormade will say um
but yeah um
as far as kicking coaches telling me
what to do they they didn't really touch
me yeah like um
i think they were just like there's that
messed up i can't even change it
it's hard though because young sometimes
young fellas or
some people come up to me and want to
like uh like kind of for me to teach
them how to place kirk
there's just no way you know it'd be
wrong for me to try and teach them the
kick
it wouldn't be right again atrocity and
um it's just one of those things i think
i repeated a bad technique so much that
i learned how to make it good and yeah
yeah it's it's probably been something
that's really helped me out from my
career you know making a few of those
clutch kicks and
you know team can rely on the boot is
good
100
mate you've always come up clutch how
many t's have you got what happens if
you lose your tailor-made tea
i drink there's a fear of mine to be
honest jimmy because there's no
replacement you only got one oh yeah i
only got that one and i don't think
another one can be made to be honest
i'm real like i'm real edgy about my ta
like even with the t-boys
like you know for all the teams i've
been in
you know i'm like i kind of demand that
it's back in my bag after the game and
um yeah
that's the one thing i demand you know
um
they make sure they put it back in there
for me so when i get back in the change
room it's always back there they know
how i am with that tears there's like
like another baby
i don't know how to sabotage you when
you come down here right i'm just
thinking i'm just thinking that
running the water
who's got my
yeah maybe i shouldn't have said that
i would never do that oh
it's just the other fellas listening to
it yeah true
but what a young mate and as always
we've gone to our instagram for some
questions and come up with plenty a
couple of your tanifa um mates have come
up trump's here by the looks of it so
we'll try and fly
through these questions of course the
most common one was around
who is the puffer fish so this is
obviously a
what a common yard
oh oh this [ __ ] you know
i don't know if you fellows have got a
whatsapp group yeah you know a team
whatsapp yeah
anyway you know you can change your um
you can change your name to like a an
icon
like
i think offer offer came into our team
this year and
like there was this hedgehog that was in
the
like he said some positive message and
it come from a hedgehog and i was like
looking at i was like who was this
positive hedgehog you know and um
next minute
i might be the puff fish or i might not
be but this puffer fish started coming
up on all the whatsapps and um
he was quite a positive bloke and um
he brought a lot of energy but now our
tunney's whatsapp's just full of icons
like um we don't even know who's talking
anymore there's like a tooth there's a
sloth
there's a turtle i think there's that
little [ __ ] emoji we don't even know who
we are like who we're talking to anymore
you know so
yeah and then but apparently the puffer
fish thing
like um all the staff got talking about
it and it was like ruining their stuff
dinners and [ __ ] they couldn't figure
out who the puff fish was
he's pretty elusive i'll tell you that
i'm not sure who he is but
yeah
that's good stuff
the elusive puffer fish okay next one
ask him about his world-class tackle
technique
i think we just went through that there
isn't technique sometimes that's the
problem jimmy i'm about to go through my
safety course on tackling so
hopefully i'll figure some stuff out
there but um i don't know it's just when
someone runs straight and it's it's man
on man
there's just something in me that just
wants to you know um i don't know i just
don't want to get uh punked on national
on tv that's probably the thing i i want
to do the punking and put it that way
and i might i just throw the bones at
them more or less and uh
yeah if i get knocked out or they get
knocked out or i get bunted or
yeah it doesn't always work and then
yeah but any malice that does happen out
of i don't intend and um
yeah it's just something that happens i
guess it's all part of being a warrior
agent you know what it's like that's uh
not quite to your levels but mate you
are wondering it's not just on tv either
like i've seen you play games of clubs
nothing you are always throwing your
body into it every collision yeah
when you've got no pedigree you know
you've got no pedigree from your parents
athletically you've got to um you've got
to throw yourself hard at them you know
you've got to you yeah these these legs
are a disgrace you know it's just a
hamstring with bones so
you've got to do you got to do what you
got to do oh mate you've done what
you've got to do you've done so well and
next one this one sounds like a yarn
actually did you and sam knock actually
share a beard in the same room for a
whole season surely
it was a top and tail
um
we didn't as i we um
one season we ended up be dan pryor
cutter fryer maddie modes and sock sam
not
we had um the prize on this little
little shack
kind of right on the beach uh it's
probably about 20 minutes out of there
yeah and we all ended up living moving
there but the problem was there was only
two rooms
or three rooms and um it was tiny and
you know me and sock being the young
fellas we drew the short straw and um
had the top and tail it was a close nine
and ten combo you know half that team
combo it's paid dividends over the years
yeah good pillow talk
right that's low so the whole year you
actually slept in the same bed yeah we
didn't really have a choice there or we
could sleep on the hard floor but yeah
um
yeah it was just a small little shack
like it it was a it was a beautiful
place to live because we're right on the
beach and
we'd go to training then we'll come back
and go out in the boat or play golf or
whatever
but um i guess one of the sacrifices you
make is um
the betting arrangements are a bit
rougher and
then sock had to make doing
yeah yeah
you know the nine and ten combo has paid
dividends years later so
were either of you in a relationship at
the time he was he's been he's been with
um his girlfriend for a long time since
since high school i think and um how
does she feel about it
oh no she just said his longest is a
gentleman uh it's all right
like luckily enough it was a gentleman
[Music]
and and you pushed him onto the um couch
in the lounge when you bought something
that
yeah exactly there's a long way to bring
something back jimmy is 20 minutes out
of town but um
yeah
it's down written really
oh that's good stuff i thought that was
made up but that's good okay next one
talk to me about your famous kick pookie
park from the sideline yeah oh that was
the first game this year um
now there's there's nothing really about
it it was just one of those kicks you
know we
i guess it was a big game for us because
after last season we um needed to start
on the right foot
and the nike had been going so well you
know last year i don't even know if they
lost the game
so um we went
yeah we went there and um
yeah we i think we scored a try with
a couple minutes to go and it was 11 all
or something but um
now it's just one of those kicks on the
sideline like yeah i don't know you know
you just be you know it's like jimmy
just back your back your years of
practice and whatnot and
yeah and whack it over the real the real
thing was the boys getting the ball over
the line you know i felt like i could do
the rest and yeah we got the win so i
was good right you always come up clutch
and you've had a few clutch kicks in
your in your time too few on the 80th
minute
um needed to kick it to win
you've always come up trumps
oh i don't know about always i've
probably missed a few but there's been a
few like good ones that i'll always
remember and cherish and people still
yarn about and whatnot but um
yeah you know it's part of your job i
guess and um
you just got to back you what you've
been doing and you're training i guess i
sinners veins
oh dan hawkins okay next one this is
from our major sponsor swiss shout out
to swish if you could get a video shout
out from any celebrity who would it be
and why
oh
any celebrity um
i don't know probably someone like um
a big time boxer maybe mike tyson oh
yeah um someone like that he's got that
same aggression as yeah that um kk saw
oh
yeah i don't know about that
yeah probably something have you ever
thought about getting into boxing uh
yeah yeah i actually um
did a bit of matt matic one of the boys
and the tonys he's actually had a couple
fights in the mma stuff
and i actually trained with him in the
lead up to one of his fights
and um you know i quite enjoyed it but
uh
getting the punch in the face for free
is no fun
you know so
i don't know yeah yeah it was something
like that but i do enjoy the art of um
of watching fights in
yeah i could see you you're a bit like
dan hooker to me i reckon you'd you'd go
real good in there
yeah i don't know i don't know yeah
i hope my chin isn't palmer says you'd
say jimmy i don't think it's a pumice
chin but
it'll be stronger than cake cookies
oh
there's pumice plains everywhere yeah
i always remember that
yeah okay
next one who's the biggest battler
you've played with
oh
man there's been many
it's hard to narrow them down
um
i have to say probably one of my waitai
teammates
bradley hyde
he um
yeah he was a he was a true battler to
the sense of it and um
he had a hell of a lot of ticker
that's for sure and he had the haircut
to boot but
yeah it's hard to even explain how much
a good battler he was to jimmy to be
honest i can't do it justice i do love a
good battler it's something i mean
people often refer to or even refer to
yourself as the great white battler um
take good pride in being a white battler
don't you ah yeah yeah well you got to
know what you are
that's what i am so yeah
um
yeah i'm not going to try and be someone
i'm not i'm in the same club for sure
okay next one i don't know jimmy you've
got a bit more pedigree than myself i
reckon
last question
best piece of advice you have for
woodland listener always love finishing
on a piece of wisdom and
who better than dan hawkins
yeah
as i said bro
footy wise and stuff for me it was a big
part of it is being grateful for what
for what's happened and what you got and
um like because like even
in pro footy
like the days the training days some
boys say i was like you know it's a long
day and whatnot but i don't really see
it like that you know i actually love
being there and um
and
it's
it's not really a long day to me you
know so i'm just great yeah just
grateful in that regard but
also as i said i think for a lot of
young guys that would kind of be in
similar shoes to me maybe didn't go
through like the under 20 program new
zealand and stuff they're trying to go
the the lower out um
just knowing like when
as i said reading reading
what's happening in your career like
there might be times you've got to move
on there might be times where you've got
to put your head down and go harder um
but i think reading the business side of
it
as well and just knowing when to get in
and when to get out when to go hard it's
pretty big but um
yeah
just love what you do i reckon mate love
that what a way to finish an
unbelievable podcast
oh dan hawkins mate it's been awesome
having you on the podcast i mean i
remember you coming into tasman as a
young 18 year old lad such good value
always keen to learn always keen to do
what's best for the team that's a few of
the things i remember i had no idea you
were going through a massive court case
at the time but mate it's been awesome
following your journey over the last 12
years taking you all around the world
everyone's got a story of their time
with dan hawkins you're one of the true
lads of the game here in new zealand so
it's been awesome to catch up with you
on the podcast i appreciate it jimmy um
you're one of the true lads yourself bro
and i'm appreciate it even my time at
tazzy bro you're always good to me and
definitely looked after me and um
congratulations on what you've done
after your career to be honest it's
quite inspiring in itself and um with
your podcast and uh and your new gig at
the crusaders
um good to see the lads that you play
with
kick on and do well bro you know it's a
beautiful thing so um thanks for having
me on jimmy it's been a privilege bro
and um wish you the best mate you are
one of the greatest lads love your work
appreciate it mate see ya jimmy thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]